hello I'm Chris Hemsworth I'm so excited
about my new film from Marvel Studios or
Ragnarok so much happens in this movie
it's
well I mean I could tell you about it
but it's gonna be a much better
experience if you buy a ticket so get
your tickets now for four ragnarok and
see you all very soon
[Music]
so much has happened since I last saw
you I lost my hammer like yesterday so
that's still pretty fresh
and then I went on a journey of
self-discovery that you
[Music]
Wow you have no idea how low the goddess
of death is invaded as God oh I've
missed this
and you and I had a fight with me today
one
now I want easily doesn't sound right
uh that's true
as god is dead we'll be reborn in Miami
I thought you'd be glad to see me need a
stopper here now to prevent Ragnarok the
end of everything
so I'm putting together a team
at the old days
surprise this'll be such fun
why
he's a fighter
we go
I'm not a queen or a monster
I'm the goddess of death
what were you the god of again
[Music]
we're the same you and I just a couple
of hotheaded fools yes same ilk like
fire door like water kind of us like
fire but a hole like a raging fire so I
like smoldering fire
you